well the reality is
you can't make a game engine that
handles everything no matter how hard
you try
he it's it's an endless path you still
see the biggest engines being constantly
updated still trying to get there with
giant teams even giant teams and
billions of dollars
can't quite get a generic game engine
finished so what makes you as a solo or
duo developer think that you can make a
game engine that does that don't forget
to like and subscribe the age-old
question
should you make a game or should you
make a game engine
most people that start to get into the
make a game mindset
or the i want to be a game developer or
i want to make a game
i have to ask this question at some
point and what tends to happen that i've
noticed is some of us that are more
i guess developer centric where we
really like the code and the math behind
it and the algorithms and understanding
what's going on
we really seem to like to
try to make a whole game engine
and making a game almost seems too easy
like we could just
open a game engine and throw things
together and it's going to get finished
quickly which isn't true
but for some reason we decide that hey
i don't want to just use other people's
stuff i'd rather
write my own
and basically i'm going to explain to
you and try to convince you in this talk
that that's
it's a bad idea to try to make a game
engine and
well if you're trying to make a game
it's a bad idea to try to make your own
engine and that you should basically use
stuff that's already available
i'm sure
there are
people that have better examples than my
personal examples but
my personal journey has also told me
this
all right so if you're going down this
route where you want to be a developer
here's
some things you should understand about
game engines and about what you're going
to get into if you're going to try to
create your own
well first
you should understand the core concepts
of a game engine that's
pretty important because you need to
know what you're getting into
and what you're signing up for
and what kind of time you'd be saving
if you're using something that already
has these done rather than have having
to recreate and re-understand all these
and this is not an all-inclusive list
this is actually what i would call a
short list
the windowing well windowing's not too
hard on most os's
you can find guides for it
the input input usually kind of comes
along with windowing
it's not super hard but it can get
pretty complicated when you're trying to
like adapt things for first person or
s and stuff like that or change the
controls when you change scenes it can
it can definitely get a little confusing
game objects how do you how are you
going to handle your game objects now
this is something that i've debated a
ton and i don't know the right answer
for this it seems like every engine has
a different name for them or a different
theory usually there's like an initial
position node and then you can attach
more stuff to that
that's usually how it is but not always
so how you gonna do it that's something
you're gonna have to think about and
understand if you're making your own
engine
cameras you're gonna support one two
multiple um all the different projection
styles you can allow people to do
whatever they want with them there's a
lot of stuff like that too you're gonna
start with a game object node and then
call it a camera or as a camera its own
separate thing
you got to decide and program that all
up if you're making your own game engine
physics you're going to write your own
physics bring in an api it's a pretty
big
thing and a pretty big commitment
to have to program and set that all up
uh how are you going to do layers in
your engine layers of graphics of ui of
whatever it may be
that's another thing you have to think
about
the graphic apis how you gonna plug in
directx vulcan or opengl or whatever
you're using
you're gonna have to set up that whole
api
whereas if you're using the game engine
it's just always it's gonna be already
done
basically and shaders are going to
support custom shaders you're going to
write your own you're going to write all
the lighting in the shaders and the
shadowing and
the animations and handle all that
i've tried it's hard and uh
yeah sound
you gotta put that in there too every
game needs sound this and there's tons
more this is just like a short list off
the top of my head basically so that's
the kind of things you need to think
about if you're thinking about writing a
game vision these are these are the
things you don't even have to really
worry about too much if you're using a
game engine just to make your game so if
you're just focused on making a game
you want to have all these available but
you don't want to have to take like a
week or a month or whatever it may be
to figure out the individual thing
because you won't even be able to get
started
on your real thing on your real project
for a long time
and the next thing you should do
and this might be really obvious i think
it segues quite nicely is you you should
start exploring some game engines
now you can go on forums and and talk to
people on discord and stuff and ask what
for their opinion
and their opinion probably is pretty
important because
in theory they know more than you if
you're just getting into this but what
these engines will show you
is
well they're all a little different and
they all basically end up doing the same
thing you're going to work with position
you're going to work with vectors you're
going to work with
potentially matrices you're going to
work with structures of data that gets
changed
and you're going to work with game
states
now all these are not game engines uh i
know you know game maker studio is and
unreal and godot and unity are but like
processing is more for like making demos
um
with just graphics in general not
necessarily games
so it might be more for algorithms and
stuff
and and
but you can make games with stuff like
that
so it's just another
another example of something to explore
and see how they've done it once again
not an all-inclusive list there are tons
more feel free to leave comments down
below if you know of more good examples
of any of these points
but yeah this is just a super important
thing you should do
you know games aren't all that new of a
thing anymore they've been being made
for a really long time so there are a
lot of people out there who have just
been doing this for
like their entire life
sometimes and they have accumulated a
lot of knowledge
and a lot of them are somewhat eager to
share it
it's like a lot of learning and you
don't you know you don't just want to
keep that in forever eventually you feel
like you want to share most people do at
least so
they'll talk about it and i've provided
a link here it'll be in the description
and down below but
it's a talk
from a guy who's been doing this for a
long time and he basically
goes through these risks the points that
are on this slide basically says you
should prototype you should make a game
not an engine
and that all engines are pretty bad
now uh yeah i found this to be very true
and one of the reasons i continue
working on my own is
yeah there's no engine's perfect so
you're not gonna find the perfect engine
and everything's gonna suddenly work out
you're basically gonna have to put in a
lot of work no matter what but if you're
also trying to make the engine on top of
the game you also want to make it's just
so much more work
and really the bottom line to that is
it's not an obtainable goal it's like
you know how every new dev or every new
game dev is like i'm going to change the
world with this new mmo multiplayer 10
000 people and you know
have any of those ever happened
not really at all generally engines come
from games not the other way around
so i encourage you to listen to this
talk it's very informative it's pretty
good
and
i i think it's kind of obscure i haven't
really seen it
before well we have one more point here
and we've kind of already mentioned it
but this is super important and it's
just
really the crux that ties it all
together
you know making a game is also a massive
commitment an engine is bigger
a game is also huge
um so what is obtainable and that is
well a simple prototype
so
that's what you actually do
you simply just don't make a game like
if you're gonna make a game
now there's exceptions to every rule of
course
but
i'm thinking of kind of the solo indie
dev or a new studio
you don't want to sink
three years of your studio's time or
your time and everything
into something that is ultimately just
going to flop that feels really bad but
it's fine to sink a week into something
that's going to flop sometimes right
all right well that's all i got for you
guys i really appreciate you watching
and yeah i hope you'll stick around this
channel for more videos a lot more to
come about
code tech and tutorials and all those
things all right matt out peace guys
thank you to all my patrons it really
does make a huge difference as the
youtube ecosystem is somewhat dying for
these uh tutorials and not dying in a
good way dying in a bad way isn't it
weird how uh ill and sick and all these
words have opposite meanings it's really
confusing anyway yeah
even though my channel is doing better
and better
uh the the revenue from ads is going
down and down so
i would really appreciate it if you
would help me out on patreon and gets
the benefits that you get there
it makes a huge difference for me
and continuing to make these videos